if you do not take social media
seriously in 2024 it doesn't mean you're
going to go out of business it doesn't
mean that you're bad but you are
absolutely missing out on opportunity to
create your thing attention is the
number one asset you and I were old
school entrepreneurs yes
and if you were say in your mid 20s
today or maybe you're looking at a
career transition there's a lot of us
who are going to be doing career
transitions in the next couple years
here how would you look at things you
know it's it's first of all thank you
for having me on and honestly I I I love
your audience so the answer to this
question is going to be pretty fun I've
been spending a lot you know it's funny
you said not a scientist I I think of my
way myself that way I'm not kidding I I
was just about to say I've been in the
lab and what that means is I've been in
my head you know people see me
especially people that don't know me as
well here may see me super loud super
New Jersey maybe a couple curse words
and I'm very empathetic to the first
glance being like is this guy for real
is's a a blow hard other people love it
and it clicks just how the world works
but what's ironic is when people see me
on social media or on stages I'm talking
the whole time right even in this format
I'm going to speak a lot I even get
excited at times and interrupt you so I
apologize in advance to everyone who's
listening um but the reality is I I
spend most of my time actually thinking
my favorite thing in the world is the
shower is the walk to work is the long
flight and so I've been in the lab a lot
in my own head for the last year
especially on the concept of redefining
success I think about root cause right
you know I think about like when I think
about health and wellness I think about
like the food system is very
entrepreneur you know America's a
capital listen I'm an entrepreneur I
love capitalism but when capitalism like
anything in life goes too far it does
things like what's going on with our
food situation and right things like
that I think about these things you know
it's funny I wouldn't have pegged you as
someone who would call that out on the
show maybe I'm just being you know like
like you're you're such a a broad
spectrum entrepreneur but more media so
you're worried about the food supply too
H I think about clean eating a lot yeah
I think about I think about laws I think
about the fact that grassfed can be
worked around but grass finished can't
so when when did this come online for
you cuz I I don't know that 10 years ago
this was in your your conscious field
like what what change for you in general
like I would argue that most of the good
that's happened in my life is
curiosity and I'm also a kid that was
born in the Soviet Union so for example
my great grandma Ana when we moved to
New Jersey out of Queens the first day
she visited she in the morning when I
woke up she made me go walk outside
barefoot on the grass no kidding so
grandmothers are always biohackers if if
they were trained by their grandmother
right right especially from the old
country right my grandma spent her first
75 years in the Soviet Union which is 50
years behind America so you know or
fasting like because I grew up in my
dad's liquor store I didn't eat
breakfast or lunch my entire life I
still don't predominantly so there's you
know so anyway obviously I'm very aware
of your audience and it's funny because
the reason I'm bringing these things up
is it's how I see entrepreneurship so I
love entrepreneurship because I think it
is one of the Arenas in the world that
allow people to maximize their
joy
I love building businesses the way I see
my friends who are
poets how I see my friends you know I I
see entrepreneurship today unlike when
you and I played with it in the mid90s
even that short ago now it's cool so now
kids are forcing themselves to be
entrepreneurs and that scares me I want
people to be entrepreneurs if they are
entrepreneurs but I'm petrified if
somebody does it because they think it's
the cool thing to do thanks for saying
that well because you know this Dave
like it's really lonely and hard and it
hurts your self-esteem because unlike
school you can't hide when you fail in
entrepreneurship yeah do you hear that
interview with the founder of Nvidia I
did not well they asked him you know
what would you tell yourself you know
back when you and a friend were in your
college dorm starting Nvidia what advice
would you have and his advice was don't
do it it was you have no idea how much
suffering this is going to cause you
yeah and I from one of the most
successful entrepreneurs on the planet
right well it's funny I don't know him
and I've heard many people say that
through the years and I don't think they
actually mean it I think it's a sound
bite I for for example I think when
you're a purebred entrepreneur mhm this
is going to be a left field one I
actually think the adversity is the most
delicious side dish yeah because if
you're used to fighting correct it
changes though I've heard your your
stuff has changed as well so for me at
the beginning it it was even before
bulletproof just in Tech
entrepreneurship it was like I'm going
to I'm going to prove something to the
world or to myself and probably more to
the world like like I'm you I'm going to
fight I'm going to push this is very
common I think there's two
fuels I think there I think there's
there's chip on shoulder right I
certainly had that and I think a lot of
people had that but you know I'm very
fortunate and this is I don't love using
the word luck but this is as black and
white like luck to me as possible
between my
DNA the mother who was a suffocating
force of positivity and optimism
suffocating optimism suffocating
optimism but practicality not modern
parenting where you you also add
delusion which eliminates Merit
incredibly optimistic and positive in
sunshine but held me accountable a word
that has completely disappeared from
Modern parenting mhm and Circumstance I
believe if I was born in America as a
third generation DNA of my family
entrepreneur my life would have looked
very different
but I was born in the Soviet Union and
came here and grew up with the struggles
that gave me outrageous perspective to
gratitude when you are I believe Dave
that the greatest gift is when you are
born if in the first 10 years of your
life you are not an incredible means
you're lower middle class and below this
is the greatest way to be born that
money is not a thing in your family yet
or maybe ever but you have unlimited
happiness you've you've been taught
you've been built you've been affected
by money is not the variable of
happiness that is kind of true in the
science but a lot of the studies I found
and this is before they inflated the
crap out of the currency in the last
three years right fake all the money we
printed yep yeah it it said about
$74,000 of right I've seen that I think
you're struggling all the time and you
only have Ramen oh by the by the way I
know people who have 200,000 but are
always in debt are making 200,000 a year
and I mean it's so funny cuz I talk to
all my many of my employees I can't say
all because they don't all take me up on
my open door policy and I don't get to
everyone but it's crazy because I'm so
well known as an entrepreneur but I'm
the CEO of this company and I speak to
kids all the time that work for me they
will often bring up that their parents
were entrepreneurs if they were or the
or anti- entrepreneur right like one of
the two like a union man right like
whatever it might be and it's really
interesting this is so cliche I'm sure
this will land for everyone it's
interesting to watch them then react to
that right they either go all in on it
or they go all out on it and the ones
that go all out on it tend to be the
ones that lived in families regardless
of how well they were doing always
stressing about money because you know
there's also the other part in society
that we've lost which is there's making
money but there's also saving money yeah
and you know Dave you and I grew up when
people talked about SA money there are
people that I know and especially in
this new world with inflated dollars
like you just talked about who make a
million dollars a year and don't have a
dollar to their name because they're
buying dumb
[__]
yeah it's a it's it's a real problem I I
kind of cringe when I see you know guys
with you know 25 with a Ferrari and all
that even if you have the money when
you're 25 you probably don't need to buy
I I crd less about the savings money I
always ask myself does he need that to
patch up an
insecurity are we using things to make
ourselves happier which gets me all the
way back I'm sorry audience but I'm
coming all the way back to the answer
your question what would I say to 25 or
45 year-old depending on start or
transition please pick something you
actually
like it hasn't changed that much because
of AI or anything like that no because I
I think I think it's incredibly hard and
if you're going to build something for
yourself you don't know if you're
destined to have a $10 million business
or a
$300,000 business but if you love it if
you love Star Trek more than anything in
the world and you want to build a
business around that passion you start a
podcast you make content for social
media that then leads to Creative
Commons product like t-shirts or you you
create like you know anything literally
that's what's so amazing about the world
now you create anything a anything from
a beanie to a protein powder that maybe
is a slang term that Spock said in
episode 4 of season 3 I don't know Star
Trek very well but I'll use Star Wars
greo was my favorite Star Wars character
tier seven character in the Star Wars
ecosystem but like when you when you
know something deeply or you love
something deeply we live in an
unprecedented time in the world where
the internet the blockchain AI you these
per the mobile device we have we you and
I when we started our stuff back in the
day we didn't live in this lucky time
where we could have just done organic
content and got free distribution Dave
social media is free distribution do you
know how insane that is it's it's so
crazy you know that that caffeine
t-shirt I talked about a long time ago I
sold it to 16 countries in alt. drugs.
caffeine on uset which is basically
redit from 199 remember it right and it
was the first time someone had done that
and you know it wasn't that much money
but I was just trying to pay my rent in
tuition so I was happy about it and like
it it was very Scrappy and it it it's
one of those things though all I had to
do was talk about it to my people
because I finally found my people but
now you can find your people anywhere
well even better instead of the in the
same way that I was on Prodigy and then
the internet on the E on the E Robert
Parker Mark Squire's bulletin board
talking about wine to find my community
and then make them aware of Wine Library
you and I had to spend hours countless
hours of building Community to have a
community
today Wine Library TV started on
February 21st 2006 YouTube itself was
was created launched on December 15 2005
within two months or roughly a little
more than two months after YouTube
existed I started a longform wine show
about wine on YouTube I made a 20-minute
video I posted it 19 people watched it
maybe today 2006 Gary with his which I
was born with my Charisma and capability
to communicate and my wi knowledge with
at that point was more than half my life
cuz I started learning about it at 14
that first video Dave might be watched
by 800,000 people the first
one wow I mean it could also have gotten
80 but anybody who's listening right now
let me just give you the universal truth
if you do not take social media
seriously in
2024 it doesn't mean you're going to go
out of business it doesn't mean that
you're bad it doesn't mean that you're
like what but you are absolutely missing
out on opportunity to create your
thing that is incredible in the speed
and time if you produce content on the
internet of building awareness and
opportunity because the algorithm now is
letting the creative find its audience
when I started doing social back in the
mid 2000s and you and everybody else all
of us when we started doing 2005
6789 Myspace Facebook YouTube Twitter it
was more like email marketing you have
to make content and slowly but surely
build a following AKA list and then you
would post and 30 or 40% just like email
newsletters of your audience would see
it
today what we have is the interest graph
not the social graph the social graph
was build the following post the
interest graph is make something and let
the algorithm the AI find the audience
of the billions of people it has on the
platform that is
remarkable it's crazy remarkable H
because you don't have to do all the
sleuthing are you worried though and
this is something that I'm I'm really
thinking about when podcast first
started yes you had an early podcast I
had an early podcast
right uh you could make you could have
these convers ation and now there's a
there's one guy every single guest I've
had on my show for 10 years he'll call
them the next day and try and schedule
the same interview yep right and there's
a lot of kind of people who will go to a
website in fact you probably even have
some people in your group here's how to
ethically steal this business model no
it's not ethical stealing but they're
going in there just mirroring a
competitor's website uh right over it
feels like the the amount of of new
information and signal to noise is going
down and we're just getting an echo
chamber of a bunch of people saying the
same thing but moving their hands
differently and now with AI avatars is
it going to be impossible to find the
good stuff versus all the copies of good
stuff that are lower quality
copies I've never had the audacity to
judge what people decide is
good well no hold on that's [__] you
sell wine yes but but if you you know
what there's ratings for wine there is
and if you go watch the Thousand
episodes of Wine Library TV I would
always say trust your pallet I would say
the reason I'm doing this show is I'm
tired of people only buying what wine
spectator and Parker buy and give good
ratings and then I would say vly almost
every episode hey by the way I just
rated this wine 94 points but I love Big
League Chew I love beef jerky I love oi
I love oysters I love sweet breads I
love Jolly Ranchers and lemon heads
unless you like every single thing I
like you have to tr then this was the
thing I said 40,000 times you have to
trust your own palette so I value craft
I I think when the story you just told
me my brain went to yeah but he or she
may not be as good at interviewing as
you are so they could have the same
exact
guests but you might ask different
questions and even if they decided to
ask the same questions I believe in
energy I believe that the intent very
true I believe in the moment I believe
in all these other variables so you know
to me I listen I've had a career where
people have done slight variations and
tweaks and very slight and have built
things but I always say but what about
me I was affected by Randy the Macho Man
Savage wrestling interviews and I loved
Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy and like
when I watch my Keynotes like meaning I
don't watch them like when I'm on stage
and I do Keynotes somewhere a year or
two in I'm like wait a minute this feels
a lot like Macho Man and Eddie Murphy
mixed up with a little bit of like you
know I think that's how the world has
always worked to your point the size and
scale we're playing at now yeah right
the size and scale we're playing at now
and there's a lot and AI is coming but I
don't know you know it's funny maybe
this goes back to being suffocated by
practical optimism I'm optimistic I
believe that the cream does rise to the
top I believe that you know you don't
get to choose how much competition you
have right I don't you really don't and
I'm I like to figure out the Merit of it
and I also have enjoyed and this is also
fun being with you because we've been
through this journey and have seen each
other from a far up close at times we
have moments right Dave like you and I
both have had moments in our career yeah
sometimes we're hotter and winning more
than we are like you know you think
about all the personalities that have
come up in the internet age that you and
I can think of now early podcasters
early Twitter
personalities some come and go yeah they
have a good
year um very true other people have been
consistently around some people have
family events or their own personal this
is why I want people to choose things
they love many of the personalities that
have fallen off have fallen out because
of burnout it's so common right you
haven't burned out and you run man I
feel it like I I've seen your energy
it's it's consistently high it's because
you like what you do and because of your
optimism but there's probably something
else in there to gratitude it's
gratitude it's perspective it's brother
when I tell you man God this is like so
[__] even emotional like I just don't
know
how to Value anything other than the
health of the people around me I don't
know how to do it of course I am proud
of my career of course I'd like to do
well I'd like everything I do to do well
of of course I'm grateful for the
accolades I'm empathetic to the people
that want to tear down my building cuz
they don't know me and I don't mind when
they leave a negative comment like I'm
empathetic I just the reason I will
never run out of energy is I don't value
this stuff enough I I don't I will tell
you something I know we don't know each
other that well but I know that we like
you know it's one of those things we
have a good sense of each other even
though we haven't had the luxury of that
kind of time yet and I say yeah cuz I
hope we get those dinners and times me
too
I I I I don't value myself based on my
professional career career even though
it's my
passion I don't I don't get self
validation from Gary Vee or the
successes or the followers or the money
or the headlines I just don't I get
validation from the people that actually
know me how they speak about me behind
my back see that is something that if I
could have internalized that when I was
in my early 20s uh that would have been
life-changing for me and and I I write
all my stuff and I feel like you do too
just like like this is what you need to
know know and if you learn it early on
it profoundly changes what you do the
the amount of time you're trying to
prove stuff to other people or you're
responding to trolls and all that kind
of stuff it sucks the life out of you
and if if you just say it doesn't matter
and then if you say the level above
which is don't feel bad for you feel bad
for them could you Dave could you for
everybody who's listening really if I
could accomplish anything in this
podcast it would be to encourage you to
go try the thing you've been debating
and I know for all of you the literally
the fundamental reason that you haven't
yet started posting on social media to
do the thing because that's what you
would do we live in 2023
24 is because you're genuinely concerned
about the judgment and that judgment
that's totally true right and the
Judgment can come from your
mother right like the Judgment can come
from your
spouse the Judgment can come from your
children it could these are important
people they can come from your
co-workers your boss your best friend
and then unfortunately it can come from
Johnny pants 47 cuz you once posted
something and he said you were ugly or
stupid or you're wrong right wrong and
so for me the the level even above like
it doesn't matter which is absolutely
true is what about having empathy for
your mom who's always been negative and
has always put you down because I
promise you her mom or dad or both did
the same to her the reason I've been
able to continue to go Dave cuz again
this is a fun interview because we don't
get to catch up often and I'm sure you
but we're both watching Always is I'm
able to go because I have empathy and
compassion for the people that are
trying to tear me down not
anger so you're always welcome if you if
you find you need a job at any point to
be a facilitator at 40 years of Zen and
this is my Neuroscience company where I
teach entrepreneurs with neuroscience
how to do gratitude and empathy and
forgiveness so they can get that state I
spent six months rearing my brain to do
exactly that for but you it came you
pick this up is this from your mom 100%
And the DNA and it was look I was such a
poor student I'm not a reader I'm not a
consu I'm like this very interesting
consumer I'm consuming everything thus
almost rendering me consuming
nothing deeply curious always gravitated
towards humans here's a good one my mom
if she was you know she's very behind
the scenes my dad would do a podcast he
likes the Limelight my mom's very behind
the scenes my mom would tell you that
the weirdest thing the most interesting
intriguing thing about my childhood was
starting at about 3 to 6 predominantly
in Queens in the early 80s late 70s we
would go outside to get some fresh air
or whatever we were doing and I would
pull at her arm I would gravitate to go
sit on a bench with a stranger who was
over
80 holy crap that my great grand that my
great-grandfather who passed away
unfortunately pretty quickly after we
got here was my best friend in my
youth I'm my Granda yeah my
great-grandfather Shia that there you
know now I and I can I don't remember 3
to 5 but I remember 6 to 10 when when
grandparents would visit my friends and
again I'm an 80s baby so we were outside
at all the time and when a grandparent
would come for the holidays or a
birthday and they'd come to the park
where we were playing basketball or
baseball or whiffle ball or football I
would always go out of my way to go talk
to them and now in my you know
especially you know don't forget I was
34 years old before even I started any
level of a public life so I was a I I
know myself because I lived it like I I
spent my 20s and my early 30s building a
business for my father I owned none of
Wine Library I never got paid much I I
wanted to give back to my parents I was
very unique I'm a first generation
immigrant I was born in the old country
I was in a cocoon I wasn't a good
student I didn't go to a university that
expanded my world I like was family
business immigrant life cocoon didn't go
out like I was closed in this beautiful
closed environment that made it unique
which is why now in my 40s I'm like ah I
loved
wisdom I'll give you one right now we
Champion youth yeah we want to look
younger we love the kids have more say
you know gen Z even young Millennials
had more say with their parents and in
the workplace than our Generations we we
we clap for the Youth 70 years ago we
clapped for the
elderly wow and I believe we're in the
pre-dawn of going back I believe in the
next 20 to 30 years after this chapter
of our over Obsession of Youth we will
counter it cuz that's what we do over 50
and 100e windows and I believe that you
will start to see
signals right now no because we're in
generational Warfare I've never seen the
level of Judgment of Boomers versus genz
and gen Z versus Millennials it's really
unfortunate humans have found another
thing to tribalize to me mad at each
other and it breaks my heart but I do
believe you will see more back to social
media and branding I believe you will
see more breakout stars who are in their
70s ' 80s and '90s
start pod if you're listening right now
and you're 70 and older please start
please start a podcast called the wisdom
week or what I or what I've learned and
and and don't be insecure here let me
everybody who's 80 has something massive
to put deposit to the world tell us
about your life tell us about what you
learned because that's what I've always
been drawn to so I think to answer your
question where did this come from I
think I came out a 90-year old man wow
you know this is also just an enormous
drop of
knowledge the reason I started the
biohacking movement is because when I
was 26 and my health was failing and I
had brain fog and arthritis and um just
all the bad stuff I hung out with a room
like 60 to 100 people in their 70s 80s
and 90s who taught me longevity before
it was supposed to be done and that led
to me becoming an expert in field I
didn't know how to to do it so I ask the
old people right and old people know a
lot and the crazy thing is they want to
share it they have a lifetime of wisdom
and they got nothing else to do with it
but just share it and especially now
because families unfortunately are not
respecting their elderly especially in
America more than ever and they're just
sitting around with so much to give
which is why I'm telling all of them
that are listening don't wait for your
grandchildren to ask start a podcast
yeah go make Tik toks tell us cuz my
great I'll tell you exactly when in
August of I'll tell you the exact month
in August of
1982 my Babushka Ana when I woke up
instead of making me breakfast took me
outside in my bare feet and made me walk
on the grass for 15 minutes and now it's
cool to do grounding in 20 you know they
know they totally and when we used to
drive on the highway my grandma Esther
and my Babushka Ana they would go crazy
when they would see something in the
grass on the side of the highway and we
would pull over and we would pick it and
we would bring it home and they would
dry it and make it tea now I've learned
all these years later that's that it's a
St John wart or wart yeah right it's
called z boy in Russian we would
literally be driving to like the beach
or to the store and out of nowhere I
mean we'd be listening to like Michael
Jackson or Cindy ler and look radio if
we you know out of nowhere my grandma or
uncle or my great grandma would be boy
boy which would mean my mom would have
to pull over on the highway we had bags
plastic bags in our trunk and we would
go outside and to I'd have to go out
there as a seven-year-old and pull the V
boy and we would fill the bags and like
you know and then 30 40 years later I
hear people on social or podcast or
wherever I see it or over dinner talk
about like hey there's this thing it's
good for depression or things of that
nature and I'm like wait a minute I
Googled it and I looked at I'm like
[__] that's v a boy you know and
so there's a m i mean especially people
that are from outside the US cuz the US
has always been a modern society you get
some real oldw world [__] from The
Immigrant grandparents and you don't
even have to do it with your own
grandparents I I didn't I just mentioned
two of my grandparents I I really only
grew up with a grandma a great grandma
who had dementia pretty early a great
great great-grandfather who I told you
died very early other than that my mom
lost her mom at five my dad lost his dad
at 16 so when you ask me about me I grew
up fearing my parents dying so much fear
death of course so much that once they
didn't by the time I got to 18 I kind of
went into I
won and now I'm just going to like live
on pure gratitude and yes and it's
really wild like I would actually argue
that in my essence
mhm I'm the most opposite of what people
think an entrepreneur is I would say
that it's weird that I became an Entre
like if like I'm so simplistic like I
dream I love the idea of living in an
incredibly remote town and making my own
food and going to sleep at se like I I
would have crushed
1643 but there was one other thing one
of my DNA traits is I'm an entrepreneur
and did want to sell flowers when I was
five and I did want to sell lemonade and
when it snowed and everybody sled and
played snowball fights I did ring
doorbells and shovels like driveways so
this weird mix but all this movement
today I think parallels into
entrepreneurship importantly so I'm
going to recall it all the way back I
believe in the same way that the
biohacking and food and mental health if
we can reframe
entrepreneurship and tell people don't
follow follow the next Trend it's not
about is cannabis hot or crypto is hot
or real estate is hot or apparel is hot
or coffee like No No's always hot there
you go brother no no what do you like
Susan what do you like en ra what do you
like Jonathan Johan Samuel like what are
you about you're into music okay through
hell high water your business needs to
be about music because here's why I prom
promise you to everyone who's listening
if you make
$318,000 a year doing
music you will be 4 billion times
happier than making $730,000 a year in
real
estate
100,000% that the number of friends from
business school who went into management
consulting and banking where you make
the most money almost all of them are
terribly miserable you know just
vulnerable they're vulnerable substance
abuse they make you millions of dollars
a year but it's not worth it because
you're selling your life to do that
You're vulnerable You're vulnerable even
even the ones Dave that don't fully
crack right the ones that don't do
substance abuse the ones that don't have
infidelity the ones that don't like do
whatever humans do uh food like you know
many people just eat their way out of
their you know you know because they
because they because they they had the
gene to not use drinking and drugs but
they're using food or something that
people don't see they use weekends and
holidays and interests to deal if you
here's one my friends who are listening
again respecting living [__] out of this
audience having a good sense of what
they was built here from afar I know how
thoughtful the people are that are
listening to this podcast and what
Journey they're on I don't know where
they are in their Journey but I get this
I have a sense that you're on this
journey for more thoughtfulness and all
this stuff I'm you have to hear what I'm
about to say my friend friends if you're
a human
being that wakes up on Friday and you're
a
static for the day to end and you wake
up on Monday and you are crushed that
the week is starting you are in a not in
a good place I'm telling you you're not
it doesn't mean you don't love your
family and what you do on the weekend
that's remarkable but if you're in a
place where you are so not fulfilled at
work that you live for the weekend
and we're filming this I don't know when
you're going to put out but we're
filming it on the Tuesday before
Thanksgiving yeah and all of us are
excited in America and other places that
you know obviously it's fun to spend
time with family and I know that all the
jokes that ants Su and all that but you
know I I if you know it's great and
vacation and late August and Christmas I
get it but I'm no I'm talking to the
people and I'm hoping you're listening
to this randomly on a Friday or Monday
and this hits you in the core my friend
if you are really unhappy I'm not naive
I love when people think and consume my
content and they think I'm delusional
I'm aware that you have I know that you
have debt I know that you have bills to
pay I'm talking that happiness is worth
fighting for happiness is worth selling
your
home to get out of debt and rent a house
or an apartment even though the re
you're all all of you are not doing this
because of judgment happiness is worth
fighting for if your job is killing you
how are don't come home and use Netflix
or food or alcohol or video games or go
into your favorite sports teams games as
you're escaped from work use those
evenings to crush on LinkedIn to get a
job offer to get you out of
it you
cannot with the amount that the world
works even though we've got it better
we're better than we've been with work
life balance in America other parts have
it better by the way on work life
balance some people are a pig and [__]
working 70 hours a week some people are
devastated working 25 hours a week when
it's not right you must fight to change
it even if you have to take a step back
in front of all your family and friends
with your luxuries go exchange the BMW
to the dealership and drive a Toyota
don't go to the Four Seasons when you go
to Disney go to the holiday end like I
did when I was a kid like it's okay
humble like don't buy seven I'm sorry on
this one David don't buy $7 coffee make
your own tea for a little while reform
your dollars to give you the breathing
room to reset your life because if you
do not like what you do it encapsulates
your entire it it suffocates everything
that's entrepreneurship that's work
that's my relationship with it and just
like with food and mentality we've made
huge advancements in the last 20 years I
don't believe that we've gotten to the
301 401 conversation I believe what I'm
talking about today which is not the
common talk of Entrepreneurship will
become the normalized talk in 25 years
that will understand that the joy of the
process not the riches we get from it is
the game of Entrepreneurship and work
and that is what we have to fight
for it is
except do you have to fight for it I I
feel like the fighting part was really
the first 35 years of life right I'm
fighting and some of that came from
being bullied to be perfectly honest
makes sense right and and at at a
certain point I did enough of the
Gratitude
forgiveness the neuro feedback the
meditation around the world all that
kind of stuff and I just realized I'm
moving toward something that matters so
I feel like I was fighting for the first
half in the second half I was moving
towards something greater and there was
a a quantitative shift in it you are you
and I are saying the same exact thing
what I'm saying is but it wasn't a
fighting energy at the it was like I'm
going to do this because it's what's
important it's what matters for the
world because the first part was your
fighting yeah yeah so how people make
the shift from fighting against towards
moving into honestly I view that as
semantics okay Dave right like I I swear
I do what I'm saying is if you're 49 and
you're sitting and listening to this
which many 49 year olds will given our
audiences I can't let you out of the
goodness of my heart and my I'm a hoper
I love to Hope I will hope I can't let
you just throw up your hands and say
well it's not in the cards for me to
enjoy my professional
career Gary you don't get it like I'm
pretty good my teenagers are 15 and 14
just a couple of more years and I'll I I
just I think that's worth fighting for
challenge yourself look you actually
we've known each other long enough where
maybe you noticed somewhere about eight
or nine years ago my physical health got
better I got better and and when I tell
you nothing on Earth comes less natural
to me than eating well and working
out and I mean nothing and I lived my
whole life being a poor student but
being successful being liked and being
successful and so I thought I was one of
these people who was crushing what came
easy to them and
punted right because I wasn't even
willing to get C's I got D's and Fs so I
thought in my 20s oh I know who I am and
I saw that in my mother if it comes
natural quadruple down superhero smart
if it would and I agree and I still
believe in that but what I thought was
doesn't come natural
punt I'll give you one in business and
in life that I struggled with Gary ve on
a podcast like this canderous at a Hall
of Fame level Gary vaynerchuck the human
being at work if he liked you which
usually happened within the first two
days of you working for him could not be
canderous cuz he didn't like delivering
bad news which led to all the sloppiness
in my career you know same here that's
that's you could almost say that twice
yes you got to be you got to be kind not
nice that's right there's uh I hope I
can find my
book I don't see it let me no anyway my
last book 12 and a half I see it there
but I won't make a mess of it um I call
it K cander my half I talk about 13
traits that I think are really needed to
win the game one man's humble subjective
point of view of business and being a
leader and I called it 12 and A2 cuz I
wanted to be vulnerable and say this
one's a big one it's called K cander I'm
only at a five out of 10 right now and
by the way that might be nice me grading
my own homework today I'm probably a
four out of 10 but [__] three four years
ago I was a one out of 10 and when I
look back at my 25 years the only people
that know me that don't feel remarkable
about me were people that I wasn't able
to be canderous to and I had to fire and
I surprised them cuzz I didn't warn them
them and more importantly now that I
look at it my the reason I used to think
it was good that I wasn't deploying K
cander was I didn't want people to be
scared and I I I hate fear Dave when I
tell you what I spend a lot of time
thinking about is how people weaponize
fear on everything and how much it
breaks my heart well I thought I was
doing this great thing as a boss cuz I
people weren't scared what I realized
the lowest point of my professional
career was when I realized oh my God
people now really know me in my
and because they know they might get
surprised fired because they've seen it
happen to others they're actually scared
my lack of cander is creating fear and
it's changed everything for me
personally professionally and so anyway
I know I'm bouncing around because I'm
excited to be on this show and I'm
hoping somebody gets value out of this
talk there there's Great Value you're
teaching people the stuff they don't
teach you in business school about about
how to think I think so like I I I I
really I think these things really
[__] matter I think the EQ part of
life I'm just IQ is getting commod [__]
with AI I mean like [__] the IQ is
getting
commoditized it's the EQ I love that it
it is the EQ and I've lost at least $100
million from allowing people to be in
leadership
positions um where I should have been a
lot much more quickly uh I should have
been a lot more direct about things that
that I didn't like but I was you know
and from body listening for everybody
who's listening who who wildly agrees
with Eric and has no question the reason
I've been able to build companies has
been based on being thoughtful about who
you fire and why other than like dramat
like I don't I I have a even when
someone's completely [__] me and
their fellow workers I don't really want
to hang them out to dry in Town Square
but I'm not but I definitely make it you
know known to why one is no longer here
yeah um but I will say this this and I
want everyone to hear this I am
predicting that $100 million number is
low the probably the hidden loss of
compromising your
values because someone is effective at
their job is the great economic loss of
every
company especially when someone has a
sales when you have a sales organization
and you can see that Johnny is the
number one salesman and he bigger than
number two 3 4 and five combined but
he's the biggest [__] on Earth what
nobody realizes is that number 2 to 40
on your 40 person sales team the second
he's gone all Elevate up 20 to 50%
because they're spending 50% of their
energy on the anxiety of having Johnny
around it's so true I I had a
salesperson
recently gave away a million dollars of
my of my ad spaces without telling
selling anyone so she could get her
little bonuses approved her own deals
all the dirty stuff that sales people
are prone to do and and we caught her
and and of course in a situation like
that it's oh no it it's the company's
fault it's not their fault and as soon
as we cleared that person out the other
people in the company they blossomed and
flourished and were serving customers
better and making clean deals but you
don't know and if you just look at the
top line so yeah if people in a cultural
fit you have to let them go and and
quickly and I think that's true for
friends as well b a big believer in that
I and I don't I think the reason people
struggle with the friend part and I'll
go back to the salesperson the friend
part is a challenge for people cuz the
world is too
absolute yeah Dave the reason so many
people just heard that and said ah I
know Johnny is toxic in my relationship
he's an asker yes we were best friends
from first to third grade but like but
[__] for the last 25 years of adulthood
he's he's played on that and all he does
is ask and really doesn't provide
anything genuinely you know whether it's
monetarily or emotionally takes gives
zero but I'm loyal I'm you know like
I I need you to hear this you don't have
to cut people completely out and a lot
of times this is what's going on with
people's parents siblings we have not
learned because the world is absolute
they hear this and be like well can't
cancel fully cancel and never talk to a
friend or a family member ever again
like that sounds not productive and
you're right but what about
limiting you know when the whoever is
the most negative force in you are what
your surroundings are if you talk to
your mom four times a day and all she
does is [__] on your sibling [__] on
your dad [__] on her boss if she is a
negative Nelly and by the way I grew up
in a family of extremes my my mom was
the most positive my dad and more
specifically his mom and my great-
grandma who I've referenced were
uncomfortably
negative and so I and I'm talking
extremes on both sides so I got this
upbringing where I really saw the world
through two very different sets of eyes
and I'm a very big believer that the
world is how you see it if you went into
my Instagram feed right now Dave you
would think the world is filled with
Sunshine rainbows and unicorns and
that's how you see it it's also what I
engage with if you engage with content
of someone helping a kid cross the road
if you consume that if you do you know
how fast you can make social media more
positive go to Instagram or whatever
platform you like Tik Tok YouTube shorts
Twitter search Happiness joy positivity
Optimus advancement upgrade search these
things well played consume it and then
like and follow things that are actually
positive and then watch how the next
morning you wake up people are always
like people love to not be accountable
just like you're salesperson it's the
algorithm's fault no it's not the
algorithm is just smart at knowing you
social media isn't changing you social
media is exposing you
oo so good it's real brother it's real
and we've got to fight and I I like
fight but I'm I'm I'm the same way as
you like I can change that I used to
word use the word hustle because I I
believe that work ethic is one of the
variables to have a 1% life mhm the
world kind of canceled hustle like
that's bad I'm like okay no problem
heart I now use work ethic just like you
jumped on early and I like it maybe you
don't want to call it fight you want to
go uh lean into upgrade towards I'm I'm
agnostic it's about willingness and
ability to work hard when it's called
for instead of doing it reflexively and
stupidly and and yes and where I'm going
on this little mini
rant you're worth it there you go it's
worth
it it's worth it it's what people don't
realize is that everyone most people are
in some version of an abusive
relationship with
themselves yes Dave insecurity for what
as if not every other person on Earth
sucks at a lot of things too we all suck
at tons of
[__] stop putting others on a pedestal
to only undermine yourself when in
essence a parent likely put that
insecurity negativity into you like you
don't hate yourself as much as you think
you don't think you think as much as you
think you are borrowing the words of
something that happened along the way
and you are capable right now to start
the process to not do that
anymore wow so all right seven eight
years ago we met at Jason Gay's an
amazing Mastermind event and you were on
stage and I think you were going through
something right then you you said you
know I I would give anything to someone
who could just teach me how to meditate
how to be happy like there has to be a
way I don't know if you remember that
talk you and I both give a lot of talks
I don't I and I'm being really serious
with you this is very important I I
believe if you you know it's funny that
your brain recalls that and the video is
online it's not it's not how I
positioned it what I was say what I was
saying was it was cool to me that
meditating was exploding yeah and that I
was scared to meditate okay there you go
because I'm in such a good place that
I'm actually scared that if I start to
meditate that I might [__] something up
I get it yeah yeah that's a much better
translation of what my brain recorded
yeah it was it I I was saying that for a
long time a lot in a lot of talks about
5 seven eight years ago cuz obviously
meditation was starting to get its
momentum and and by the way I'm still in
that place I and I as I've watched the
space and as I've watched people get the
value of it cuz I'm a big believer mhm
I'm kind of in this new state where I'm
like [__] I'm meditating at all
times that's what I'm picking up like I
I I can I spent many many years so
there's you read people whatever you
maybe you're born with it but I I want
to know so when you lean into the camera
and you do this and you say something
that really matters to you your eyes
change and you're actually transmitting
energetically and I can pick that up and
so can everyone else whether they know
they are they don't know they are
picking that up that's one of the
reasons you're powerful media is that a
skill you learned or have you always
done that I've always done that okay
that's just part of who you are I I I I
realized that most of the reason I was
able to get through school with the even
though that I should have stayed back
every grade since fourth grade if we're
going on the Merit you know if you don't
do homework ever and you get an F on
every test and you don't pay attention
in class unless it's history cuz you're
genuinely interested interested in it
you shouldn't
pass but they passed me a probably for
self-interest of you know cuz the
school's going for a blue ribbon and
need everyone passing or all those
things I've come to learn that or what
I've now come to believe is my Charisma
my teachers loved me I never I was an
atrocious student but in the history of
school because of the way I was parented
I never disrespected a teacher I might
have been disrespecting the craft by my
behavior right by not pay by talking to
my friend and trying to sell him
baseball card or talk about wrestling or
about the Jets game while a teacher was
you know giving a lesson I can respect
that that is a form of disrespect but
with words two I always I never did it
once and so you know I look I was the I
was the president of my fifth grade
right so clearly clearly when I look
back at like like I don't even know why
I did it right but I did it like yeah I
mean but but there's also another thing
that comes along with this which
is I really like people I actually have
a very weird relationship with dogs this
is very tongue and cheek so don't get
all upset with me everyone but I do have
a funny like I anytime I'm in the world
and I see people hutter around a dog and
they love the dog I always think to
myself man I wish we did that for each
other this unconditional love that we
are able to as a society to deploy
towards dogs and I know what going to
say well that's cuz they unconditionally
love you
yes but where is our capacity to be the
bigger person like why do you need
someone else to do something for you why
not take it on yourself to do it for
them because oh by the way you're doing
it for yourself in that
[Music]
framework yeah you got to do that to
yourself the self-love and not maybe not
self-loathing it was back to an early
point you said 90% of people that I see
become successful went down your track
with a chip on shoulder yeah I'm in a
very small group and if you part of this
and you're listening please call your
parents and kiss their faces I am in a
small group of people where gratitude
was my fuel not
insecurity Gary when are you going to
write a book on parenting I've been
writing a book in my head called
perfectly parented yeah there you go
please please write that it would be an
active service I'm going to write the
book from the perspective of being the
one who was parented yeah I'm I'm also
so like I'll say it here because I think
parents need to hear this even though I
spend my life 20% of my communication
putting my parents on a pedestal I could
spend an entire another hour with Dave
on a podcast telling you all the things
my parents did that I don't think was
great it's the it's the flight of a
human like it's what we go with it's
just that I wish that everybody would
stop spending 100% of their energy
pointing to one to Seven Things their
parents did wrong instead of the many
things they did right so you got it
Balan view you've got good and bad most
people go all good or all bad one that's
true so you you see reality for the way
it is you you'll like this I
I my I have a new book coming out next
year called day trading attention which
I think is going to be a smash because I
think it helps everyone everybody would
like whether it's a nonprofit or their
personal brand or the company they work
for or their startup or their Instagram
page or running for mayor in town
everybody is starting to wake up to the
fact that if you're unable to Garner
attention on social media you're not
going to be able to pull off the thing
you want selfless selfish and everything
in between the the the cover is purple
Dave because of what you and I just
talked about all of the answers to our
unrest is in the
purple life is about the purple
happiness is in the purple so well said
the reason everyone is so G
and they will point to everything but
the accountability of their journey to
move to the purple they are either red
or blue it back to fear the
weaponization of fear parents think
about how you talk to your children if
you do that I'm going to do this all we
are weapon bosses if we don't hit our
number someone's not going to be
here fear and then we're eliminating
Barrett one last thing while I'm on this
eighth place trophies is not a good idea
oh man I was going to ask you more about
that CU yeah that that is rotting the
world teaching teaching
indifference is
devastating worst thing you could ever
do and that's what you're doing it
doesn't matter tell that to a kid who's
born competitive tell them that their
seventh their seventh grade championship
basketball game hey Johnny it's okay
don't cry that's silly this doesn't
matter [__] you it matters much more
than my report card which is completely
subjective and ridiculous this is real
life mhm like we we we have we have
misplayed a couple of hands in parenting
that if we tweak we can have way more
joy back we are we are I'm just going to
throw this one out my friends cuz I'm
just trying to throw a couple deposits
that maybe make someone think about it
if you have a 27-year-old child and you
were paying for their lifestyle it's
bad yeah you have they want they and as
someone who gets 10 I'm going to say
this nice and slow as someone who gets
10,000 direct messages a day and who
when he goes on long flights reads tons
of them I was taken a back 10 years ago
when I realized the resentment of
26-year-old nepo baby has to their
parents crazy I would read these things
and I would make a piece of a Content
that would trigger them DM me Gary I'm
like that kid you talked about in that
video I have a BMW I live in the West in
West Hollywood my parents pay for my
Equinox I [__] have a [__] job
because I don't it doesn't matter cuz my
parents pay for everything and they
think they're and like and I thank them
and they think they're doing the right
thing but deep down you're right I
[__] hate them and what what that
means what just to give everyone the
preview when you pay for your kids and
their
grown-ups you're telling them that you
don't believe in them there you go that
they're not capable y they can't fly
you're never going to kick them out of
the nest and the second they smell that
you're really doing it because you
actually care what your friends you the
parents friends think about the kid and
they become an object to your
self-esteem then it's
tipped
yep and you've got so much wisdom Gary I
I greatly admire the way you communicate
and the way you're living your life and
the way you've maintained optimism even
with all the the pain that comes with
entrepreneurship and I'm not
discouraging anyone but it is more
painful than you think and it's more
rewarding than you think especially if
you care about what you're doing you
somehow stay on top of it all it's you
got you got to like it thank you brother
you got to like
[Music]
it